la crise de santé mentale convient en ce
moment elle est historique et la
cacopolytrer la marchandise et les
attentes ont pas diminué en fait au
contraire en deux ans les listes
d'attentes en santé mentale au Québec
sont passées de 16000 à 21000 personnes
est-ce que les listes d'attentes ont
autant augmenté
oui c'est vrai
[Musique]
à l'automne 2020 environ 16000 québécois
attendaient pour des services de
première ou de deuxième ligne en santé
mentale dans le réseau public c'est 21
000 en ce moment selon le ministère de
la santé c'est donc une augmentation de
30% en deux ans on va s'assurer
d'embaucher les gens pour faire ce
travail-là 900 psychologues
supplémentaires dans le réseau public et
on va bonifier immédiatement les
salaires et les conditions de travail
c'est une promesse très ambitieuse selon
l'Ordre des psychologues du Québec
on compte environ 9000 psychologues dans
la province environ 2000 d'entre eux
c'est-à-dire 23% travail dans le système
de santé publique pour augmenter leur
nombre Québec solidaire veut recruter
des psychologues qui œuvrent au privé
mais la pratique privée les attire de
plus en plus en 2020 36% des
psychologues de la province pratiquaient
exclusivement au privé aujourd'hui c'est
42% pour renverser la tendance cuise
veut bonifier le salaire des
psychologues de 30% dans le réseau
public pour combler l'écart avec le
privé on veut aussi améliorer les
conditions de travail tout ça suppose
des négociations avec les syndicats
c'est donc un engagement qui comporte
son lot de défis